j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
avec cette question en forme de
casse-tête comment assurer la sécurité
des Jeux Olympiques et notamment de la
cérémonie d'ouverture le projet de loi
concocté par Gérald Darmanin
empiète-t-il sur nos libertés avant
d'entendre nos invités les détails du
texte discuté aujourd'hui et demain au
Sénat avec Mathias
dans 18 mois Paris retrouvera les Jeux
olympiques mais sans temps après la
dernière édition dans la capitale
française les défis ont changé la
sécurité est aujourd'hui au cœur des
préoccupations
vidéosurveillance augmentée intrusion
sans billets dans les enceintes
sportives dans son projet de loi Jo 2024
le gouvernement prévoit également la
création de nouveaux délits pour le fait
de pénétrer ou de se maintenir sans
motif légitime sur l'aire de compétition
il n'y avait pas jusqu'à présent
d'infraction d'intrusion sur un terrain
de foot ou sur un terrain de tennis pour
manifester ses convictions alors il y en
a qui le font pour vraiment porter des
idées fortes il y en a qui le font aussi
simplement par plaisir et par défi qui
perturbent largement l'organisation de
ces compétitions sportives qui sont des
compétitions de jeux qui doivent être
festives ça c'est certain mais qui sont
aussi des grands enjeux économiques et
financiers qu'on ne doit pas éluder
dorénavant les contrevenants s'exposent
à des peines de six mois
d'emprisonnement et des amendes pouvant
aller jusqu'à 7500 euros des sanctions
en mesure de dissuader qui inquiète
Anne-Sophie Saint-Père spécialiste des
questions de liberté ça se place dans
une logique générale d'entrave de plus
en plus forte au droit de manifester à
la liberté d'expression donc tout ça est
un climat assez inquiétant la liberté
d'expression le droit de manifester ce
sont des droits fondamentaux que la
France a engagée à défendre du côté des
associations la nouvelle interpelle mais
n'effraie pas
donc là Elysée faut savoir qu'elle avait
pas mal la trouille quand même mais elle
s'est accrochée quand même et oui ça
pourrait être cette 1500 euros donc du
coup avec le nouveau projet de loi mais
ça nous fait pas peur ce qui nous fait
peur c'est de mourir dans le dérèglement
climatique pour Nicolas citoyen engagé
chez dernière rénovation le projet de
loi cherche à étouffer un message qui
dérange et ils ont pas envie que que
comment dire que le que le focus soit
mis sur eux et sur leur inaction parce
que il faut rien et et au bout d'un
moment donné ça va savoir ça va se voir
les Jeux Olympiques représenteraient un
énorme coup de projecteur pour les
associations en 2021 3 milliards de
personnes ont suivi la compétition
derrière leur écran
sécurité et liberté de grands piliers
d'une démocratie à l'aune de ce défi des
Jeux Olympiques voilà le thème de notre
débat avec Richard lisuret bonsoir
bienvenue ancien directeur de la
gendarmerie nationale adjoint au maire
de Chartres et membre du cercle de
réflexion initiative sécurité intérieure
Gaétan Morin bonsoir bienvenue Gaëtan
c'est de service aux Parisiens magazines
Mathieu zagrodski bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi chercher associés
au centre de recherche sociologique sur
le droit et les institutions pénales
spécialiste des questions de sécurité et
Mathilde sirop évidemment est resté à
mes côtés peut-être une question assez
générale
l'isoa vous êtes général d'armée sur sur
ce ces défis quand on s'attaque à des
jeux olympiques vous avez dirigé la
gendarmerie nationale pendant plusieurs
années
le défi sécurité est-ce que c'est le
premier auquel on pense alors d'abord
les Jeux Olympiques la première chose à
laquelle on pense c'est le sport le
plaisir de plaisir d'accueillir le monde
d'accueillir de permettre aux athlètes
de s'exprimer d'arriver à
l'aboutissement de d'une carrière
parfois et pour que justement les choses
se déroulent correctement pour que ces
athlètes puissent évoluer en toute
sécurité pour que les spectateurs
puissent venir en toute tranquillité il
faut effectivement un écosystème qui
leur permet de faire ça de manière
tranquille ne pas être agressé ne pas
être
violenté parfois on a bien vu un certain
nombre d'événements récents sportifs qui
consistait en fait à attaquer les
spectateurs donc je crois que la
sécurité c'est effectivement ce qui
permettra à ces jeux de se dérouler
correctement cette loi elle répond à ses
impératifs elle répond en partie parce
qu'il y a déjà des choses qui ont été
faites il y a une préparation qui se
fait dans la dans la durée évidemment
c'est que loi permet de mettre en place
un certain nombre d'éléments techniques
voire d'éléments technologiques qui
accroîtront les conditions de sécurité
et cette sécurité elle est indispensable
elle est indispensable pour que
justement
l'ensemble du monde puisse voir des peu
tranquille et des jeux apaisés alors
c'est vrai que on parlait de liberté la
sécurité la liberté ne s'oppose pas en
fait il y a quelques années quelqu'un
disait que la sécurité c'est la première
des libertés on est d'accord ça reste le
cas mais il y a par exemple des débats
autour des technologies notamment des
outils de surveillance caméra de
surveillance algorithme lié à ces
carburateurs on propose on vous
proposera un débat une partie de ce
débat un chapitre vraiment consacré à ça
et Gaetan Mora pour vous qu'elle quels
sont les mesures ou la mesure phare de
cette loi celle qui pourrait susciter le
plus de débats alors il y a plusieurs
choses d'abord il faut quand même
replacer le contexte il y a un gros
enjeu de sécurité aussi parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a 22000 à 30000 agents
à retrouver que le privé n'est pas
capable n'est pas à même à déjà prévenu
qu'il ne pouvait pas il subvenir donc ça
déjà c'est la première chose ensuite sur
le projet de loi en tant que tel il y a
plusieurs points qui font des bas il y a
le point technologique alors à la fois
avec la caméra augmentée autrement dit
la possibilité grâce à des algorithmes
puisqu'il n'y aura pas en revanche de
reconnaissance faciale ça ça a été
abandonné par le gouvernement
donc la possibilité par des algorithmes
de capter un certain nombre de
mouvements qui ou de comportements
anormaux mais qu'est-ce qu'on met
derrière comportement anormaux ça n'est
pas si évident ensuite le vrai problème
de enfin le vrai débat à mon avis enfin
ce sur quoi va porter le débat de cette
loi c'est quand même le la question du
temps aussi puisqu'en fait certaines
mesures devraient prendre effet avant
les Jeux de manière expérimentale et
surtout durer après les Jeux donc on se
sert aussi de la loi Paris 2024 pour
finalement améliorer un dispositif
existant qui qu'on juge défaillant
notamment depuis la finale de la Ligue
des champions qui a créé pas mal
d'incidents avec les supporters Mathieu
zagrosky alors moi je fais ressortir
l'article 12 de cette loi qui qui vise
les activistes les militants qui qui il
y aura une intrusion sur sur la pelouse
dans un stade ou des ou des actions
violentes certains ils voient une
atteinte liberté
disons en tout cas c'est de la peine
alors oui il y a aussi le fait de rendre
automatique les interdictions de stade
et où là on est clairement dans ce qui
vient d'être dire l'instant des mesures
qui vont bien au-delà des Jeux
Olympiques typiquement je pense pas
qu'il y aura beaucoup d'interdictions de
stats qui vont être prononcés pendant
les Jeux Olympiques juste pour bien
clarifier de ce dont on parle 1993
création création de l'interdiction
judiciaire de stade qui est en fait une
peine complémentaire qui peut être
prononcée par le juge quand vous
commettez des incidents autour d'un
événement sportif voilà JO sont pas des
événements qui génèrent beaucoup
d'incidents autour ou dans les sites
donc on est clairement sur quelque chose
qui a une visée allant bien au-delà des
JO et c'est pareil pour ces délits
d'intrusion ou le fait de de pénétrer
frauduleusement dans une enceinte
sportive qui est un peu une réponse à ce
qui s'est passé au Stade de France en
mai dernier ou des tas de gens en fait
se sont engouffrés dans les comment dire
n'importe dans les portiques pardon du
Stade de France pour regarder légalement
le match là encore je suis pas persuadé
que c'est quelque chose qui va être
prédominant pendant les Jeux Olympiques
on est sur quelque chose qui dépasse
assez largement cette compétition le
premier défi peut-être le plus compliqué
gaetanement c'est la cérémonie
d'ouverture ah oui 26 juillet 2024
l'idée elle est audacieuse appelée des
bateaux je le mot est faible c'est ça le
des bateaux qui vont défiler avec des
délégations paper pays sur la scène
c'est c'est quoi c'est si on fait un peu
de politique c'est vraiment Emmanuel
Macron qui l'a voulu ça c'est c'est quoi
la genèse de l'histoire la cérémonie
d'ouverture c'est vraiment l'effet
clinquant de la candidature de Paris il
fallait quelque chose d'un peu novateur
qui emporte l'adhésion qui suscite un
peu de souffle et cette cérémonie elle a
été pensée comme telle parce que bien
entendu personne ne l'a jamais faite
comme ça en plein centre-ville donc là
sur la scène le problème c'est que c'est
6 km de long à sécuriser que à l'heure
actuelle la question c'est quel jauge de
spectateur on peut sécuriser donc ça on
parle de 400 000 de 600 000 probablement
savoir revu à la baisse encore davantage
que encore en deçà de 400 000 parce que
ça va être très compliqué
il y a la partie VIP par ailleurs qui
celle-là devra payer enfin c'est pas
c'est pas eux qui paieront c'est les
sponsors mais en gros voilà il y a une
partie VIP une partie gratuite
il y a la question du filtrage comment
est-ce qu'on va filtrer les gens avant
de venir il faudra venir trois quatre
heures avant peut-être même encore plus
et par ailleurs je crois que à l'heure
actuelle dans le cahier des charges il
est prévu matondi que les athlètes
défilent assez rapidement sur la scène
mais c'est pas possible donc en vrai
aujourd'hui le cahier des charges sur la
cérémonie d'ouverture il est à revoir
alors c'est un classique bon les Jeux
Olympiques on revoit tout le temps son
cahier entre la candidature et ce qu'on
va garder est-ce qu'on va garder le
principe quand même moi j'ai moi j'avoue
que j'étais sensible à l'audace je vais
vous donner la parole à la loutre sur
cette cérémonie d'ouverture mais je vous
propose d'abord de réécouter géra
l'intérieur c'était lors d'une audition
ici au Sénat au mois d'octobre dernier
justement alors on était encore sur une
jauge un peu un peu supérieur on parlait
de 600000 regardez en tout cas si je
regarde juste la cérémonie d'ouverture
stricto censue nous sommes à 100000 en
bas 500000 spectateurs en haut
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 600000 personnes
dans l'hypersens de Paris le long de la
Seine avec des nombres problèmes d'ordre
public si jamais les choses se passaient
évidemment mal avec des endroits pas
très faciles à sécuriser en tant que tel
des ponts et des passerelles des quais
pour ceux qui connaissent ces questions
je pense que tout le monde les connaît
ici voilà qui qui parfois sont large
parfois sont plus étroits avec
évidemment une île ou deux îles même
plutôt en plein en plein milieu qu'il
faut sécuriser des gens qui habitent qui
vont pouvoir rentrer chez eux une
personne peut faire une crise cardiaque
dans ses habitations comment on y accède
vous dirigiez à la gendarmerie nationale
il y a encore quoi quelques années alors
vous étiez plus en poste je crois quand
Emmanuel Macron annonce que cette
cérémonie d'ouverture aura lieu sur la
selle vous êtes dit ouf
d'abord j'ai regardé la complexité
exceptionnelle de cet événement alors
certes un événement clinquant ça
d'accord mais quand on regarde je pense
que on pourrait pas faire pire en termes
de complexité on a la distance on a les
zones c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il y a
effectivement les spectateurs le long
des quais mais il y a aussi la zone
d'embarquement la zone débarquement il y
a l'eau il y a sous l'eau vérifiez un
peu ce qu'il y a sous l'eau ce qu'il n'y
a pas et il y a l'air puisque il y a en
même temps certains nombre de drones un
certain nombre d'animations donc tout ça
en fait c'est une complexité en 3D qui
va vraiment poser poser difficulté et ça
pose difficulté aux forces mais ça pose
aussi difficulté en termes de
compétences parce que théoriquement une
cérémonie d'ouverture c'est de la
responsabilité du CIO comme
international olympique et donc c'est
quelque chose qui est sécurisé
périmétriquement par le stade par le
stade là c'est pas le cas puisque en
fait c'est ouvert donc aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas d'ailleurs que la cartographie
des compétences soit déjà stabilisée et
qu'on sache qui fait quoi à quel moment
et qui est responsable de quoi donc
artiste c'est pas raisonnable
artistiquement c'est magnifique sur le
plan de la sécurité
bon courage bon courage encore une fois
aux responsables et c'est vrai qu'on
n'aurait pas difficilement pu faire plus
compliqué Matthieu zagroci est-ce que
bon je pense pas qu'il précédent mais
est-ce qu'il y a des événements
similaires sur lesquels la France peut
voilà s'appuyer pour chercher je sais
pas un exemple vous voyez ce qu'il faut
tout inventer quoi de toute façon
j'improvise
l'un des Jubilés de la reine
d'Angleterre il y a une grande parade
sur la Tamise je me souviens après
l'énorme en jeu par rapport à cet
événement en plus de tout ce qui a été
dit c'est l'arrivée des secours c'est
que en fait vous ne pourrez pas faire
arriver des secours par la voix par
intéresse pour avoir routière donc tout
va reposer sur la brigade fluviale de la
préfecture de police qui va falloir
gonfler ça qui leur faut des bateaux il
faut il faut former des gens en fait à
l'intervention fluvienne qui est un
métier complètement à part au sein de la
police et de la gendarmerie c'est ce que
disait le ministre de l'Intérieur si
quelqu'un fait un malaise cardiaque même
pas forcément parmi la foule qui est
assiste à la cérémonie dans les dans les
dans les appartements les maisons en
résonance il faut pouvoir accéder quoi
c'est tout à fait moi j'ai en tête ce
qui s'est passé le le jour où Notre-Dame
a brûlé on sait à quel point les
pompiers ont eu du mal ont été retardés
ont eu du mal à accéder donc ça c'est
une dimension supplémentaire à intégrer
au défi est-ce que je vous pose
exactement la même question quand vous
avez entendu enfin voilà entendu
Emmanuel Macron je crois que c'était
pendant les Jeux de Tokyo il avait
profité des Jeux de Tokyo pour annoncer
ça vous êtes dit vous avez de quoi ouais
chouette la France est audacieuse ou
alors c'est c'est trop dangereux
spontanément je me suis dit c'est
original et ça va être spectaculaire
évidemment enfin je suis par ailleurs
fan de sport
parfois je surtout si l'annonce était
pendant les JO Tokyo c'était pendant les
vacances donc on va dire que j'avais
enlevé ma casquette de de spécialiste de
ces questions là donc évidemment la
première action est celle-ci mais
ensuite quand vous discutez avec les
professionnels du secteur justement des
gens notamment de la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation qui
est en fait la direction de la
préfecture de police qui qui gère les
grands événements qui gèrent tout ce qui
est ordre public ah bah c'est sûr qu'il
y a des des maux de tête qui ont été
provoqués à ce moment là avec notamment
comme je vous le disais cette question
en fait de la circulation pour les
forces de l'ordre en cas d'événements où
il faut intervenir il y a peut-être
Gaëtan Morin aussi un des conséquences
sur l'artistique c'est à dire que il y a
des consignes qui sont données
à celles et ceux qui vont inventer cette
cérémonie d'ouverture pour qu'elle soit
pas visible de trop loin c'est ça j'ai
vu ça c'est ça l'idée
Thomas Joly qui est donc le chorégraphe
qui va devoir inventer la cérémonie
d'ouverture à peu près carte blanche
sauf sur l'enjeu sécuritaire c'est
d'ailleurs qu'effectivement il faut pas
que la cérémonie
soit visible de trop loin pour éviter
les attroupements et les effets de masse
en fait donc voilà donc il y a des
arbitrages qui seront encore qui sont
encore à donner là-dessus et puis alors
il y a un autre enjeu m'a-t-il dans ton
on va parler ensemble qui est plus
politique autour de la personnalité du
ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin en première ligne
notamment on va le réécouter sur la
question du recrutement vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure il a été annonce
le ministre nous avons décidé et en
prévision de la Coupe du monde de rugby
et des Jeux olympiques de multiplier par
plus de 2 l'effort du nombre de
personnes de policiers de gendarmes que
l'on mettra dans les transports ça passe
par 200 policiers de plus spécifiques de
lutte contre les incivilités et la
sécurité dans les transports en commun à
Paris c'est un effort évidemment sans
précédent et ça passe par en province la
création de nombreux services
spécialisés dans les transports bon
quand on connaît les difficultés de
recrutement actuel pas seulement
d'ailleurs dans ce secteur de la
sécurité ça ne sera pas une mince
affaire oui il a la pression Gérald
Darmanin il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
la préparation des Jeux Olympiques
occupe le tiers du temps du ministre de
l'Intérieur voilà c'est ce qu'il dit en
tout cas à ses interlocuteurs même si ça
ne se voit pas forcément voilà à l'oeil
nu en tout donc on le rappelle le
ministre cherche 3000 policiers et
gendarmes pour assurer la sécurité lors
de la compétition ça veut dire 30000
mobilisés par jour et jusqu'à 45000 lors
des des grands événements dont bien sûr
la cérémonie d'ouverture il a d'ailleurs
déjà préparé un petit peu les esprits au
fait que durant cet été là certains
événements par ailleurs sportifs ou
culturels pourrait être reporté ou
annulé pour avoir suffisamment de force
de l'ordre qui soit vraiment pleinement
mobilisée pour cet événement évidemment
on parle d'un événement en monovision
des milliards de téléspectateurs oui
c'est un défi immense pour le
gouvernement en termes d'organisation
comme d'ailleurs pour la Coupe du monde
de rugby en septembre prochain et c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être pas un hasard si on
a vu Emmanuel Macron lors de la Coupe du
monde de football qui n'a pas hésité à
flatter à féliciter le Qatar pour la
bonne tenue de la compétition il devait
penser lui-même à ce qu'il l'attendait
parce que le compte à rebours a commencé
et le Président on nous dit qu'il pense
vraiment du matin au soir que pour lui
c'est vraiment un grand moment de son de
son quinquennat et qu'il veut en faire
une espèce de couronnement et une
opportunité de faire rayonner la France
à l'international bien sûr il met la
pression à son gouvernement à
l'administration il veut que ça puisse
être tout simplement mis à son crédit
politique le chef de l'État a bien sûr
on l'a dit il devra faire oublier le
fiasco du Stade de France c'est aussi un
défi pour géralda maintenant puisqu'il
avait rejeté la faute sur les supporters
anglais à l'époque ces images
désastreuses et d'ailleurs c'est Didier
l'allemand dans son livre l'ancien
préfet de police de Paris qui met en
garde puisqu'il dit pour le moment
j'observe que les JO se préparent comme
la finale du Stade de France donc Gérald
Darmanin
2024 s'il est toujours en poste il
pourra à ce moment-là battre un record
de longévité avec Raymond Marcelin l'un
de ses illustres anciens mises à
l'intérieur et il s'est fixé comme
objectif de franchir cette avec succès
il en a même fait un point de bascule
dans son parcours politique
on peut dire que dans la macronie tout
le monde a accroché 2024 dans l'agenda
absolument c'est en quelque sorte le top
départ de la succession d'Emmanuel
Macron le début de l'acte final aussi de
son quinquennat politiquement il se
murmure qu'il pourrait en profiter pour
à ce moment là déclencher par exemple
une dissolution ou un référendum sur des
réformes sociales ou sociétales Gérald
Darmanin le ministre de l'Intérieur lui
il essaye de s'imposer comme
présidentiable on le voit il avance ses
pions et il se voit à la rentrée 2024
s'il réussit encore une fois cette étape
prendre du galon dans le dispositif soit
à un portefeuille important soit un
Matignon mais aussi il pense aux parties
il a intérêt au RPR à 16 ans et il
pourrait peut-être briguer la présidence
du parti Renaissance le parti du
président qui a fixé comme par hasard
son congrès à ce moment-là en
2024jeux politiques autour de
l'organisation de ces Jeux olympiques
mais je voudrais revenir à la question
centrale de notre débat et la question
de la sécurité et effectivement Gaëtan
Morin je reviens vers vous sur ce fiasco
du Stade de France si on peut-être si on
sort du regard français redites nous on
l'a évoqué mais quel répercussions ça a
eu à l'étranger et peut-être notamment
dans le premier pays concerné la
Grande-Bretagne alors d'abord il faut
quand même se rappeler que pour la
Grande-Bretagne c'est un traumatisme
tous les accidents de foule de masse
comme ça lors d'un match de foot ils ont
été ils ont été assez traumatisés par ça
dans le passé donc quand finalement
c'est peut-être ce qu'il y a sauvé le
Stade de France d'un énorme inc c'est
d'ailleurs que malgré tout même s'ils
ont été bloqués au portique les
supporters n'ont donc pas pu rentrer
dans le dans le stade alors même que
certains avaient leurs billets dûment
payer et donc il y a eu un problème de
billetterie au final il y a pas eu de
mouvement de foule c'est à dire qu'ils
sont restés calmes alors même que
certains d'entre eux étaient détroussés
par des hordes de petits voyous qui sont
venus de manière opportunes à ce
moment-là ce qui fait que il y a pas eu
d'incident majeurs en revanche des
supporters d'autres clubs d'autres pays
auraient peut-être réagi beaucoup moins
calmement que les Anglais vous ne l'avez
dit parce qu'il y a eu plusieurs drames
de supporters dans l'histoire du
football anglais liés notamment à des
mouvements de foule incontrôlés
exactement donc au moins il y a cette
résilience là chez les supporters
britanniques après dans les jours et les
semaines qui ont suivi la France a fait
la une de tous les tableaux et
britanniques avec les témoignages en
fait de ces supporters qui franchement
faut les lire ces témoignages parce
qu'en plus le ministre à l'époque donc
Gérald Darman de l'intérieur et Amélie
ou desa Castéra ministre des Sports
je crois d'ailleurs qu'on était là déjà
tous les deux
en fait on maintenu le fait que la
France n'y était pour rien ce qui était
inaudible les excuses sont venues
beaucoup trop tardivement ouais c'était
incroyable et les excuses sont venues
très tardivement à minima et donc n'ont
pas été reçus donc effectivement la
France aujourd'hui part avec ce déficit
d'image très fort et puis le Stade de
France il est quand même pas facile en
fait en termes de circulation parce que
il y a cette espèce de tunnel dans
lequel les supporters sont restés
coincés donc il va falloir dépasser ça
quand même alors peut-être moi je vais
essayer d'y voir une note positive
peut-être que finalement c'est c'est le
rappel qu'il fallait aussi au ministère
de l'Intérieur à la préfecture de police
qui a changé de préfet de police
maintenant c'est Laurent Nunez à la tête
de la préfecture de police pour voir
pour réviser vraiment le dispositif
sécuritaire à condition d'en tirer les
leçons je redonne la citation qui est
quand même frappante de l'ancien préfet
de police de Paris Didier l'allemand bon
qui peut être qui a été beaucoup
critiqué sur d'autres aspects de son
mandat mais bref il dit pour le moment
j'observe que les JO se prépare comme la
finale au Stade de France est-ce que
vous vous diriez généralement il y a
quand même eu des leçons où il y a des
leçons qui sont en train d'être tirées
forcément quoi on peut l'espérer oui
alors vu l'événement effectivement et
son ampleur et je retentissement
aujourd'hui il y a une mobilisation
générale du ministère à l'intérieur de
l'ensemble des forces on l'avait dit le
préfet du Net est aux commandes il a
activé le dispositif je trouve
d'ailleurs un peu étonnant que quelqu'un
qui était au commande à ce moment-là via
une critiquer certains trucs comme s'il
y était pour rien enfin pardon mais bon
ça c'était juste le petit peu sauté
là-dessus aussi
propre turpitude bref moi je dis ça je
dis rien mais alors avec un peu de recul
vous dites quoi qu'est-ce qu'on sait
quelles erreurs leçon on peut tirer dans
le cadre encore une fois de la sécurité
des jeux il y a eu un rapport qui a été
commandé et revit par Michel cadeau le
délégué interministériel aux Jeux
olympiques et aux grands événements qui
pointaient un certain nombre d'éléments
bon les billets papiers un certain
nombre de problèmes de flux la grève du
RER à ce moment-là avec une station
fermée donc il y a un certain nombre de
je dirais de défauts conceptuel à ce
moment-là il y a aussi un certain nombre
de travaux qui sont actuellement menés
sur le partage de l'information sur le
renseignement en amont ça c'est un
élément important à savoir effectivement
quels sont les mouvements là on parlait
des jeunes qui venaient du département
pour venir détrousser les les Anglais
bon ben un moment donné si on met en
place des outils de renseignement si on
met en place des outils effectivement
ensuite de prise en compte et c'est le
cas pour les JO il y a une organisation
des services de renseignement il y a une
organisation des services de police et
singulièrement d'apprécier Autopolis le
préfet de police a une compétence
élargie à l'occasion dans le cadre
justement du projet de loi et c'est
important d'avoir cette cohérence sur un
sur un écosystème les JO se déroulant
sur l'ensemble de la métropole mais
notamment donc ce sera le préfet de
police l'homme qui est ministre de
l'intérieur de la plaque parisienne
c'est évidemment préfet de police
s'agissant du reste du territoire parce
qu'il y a pas que les JO pendant les
lieux la vie continue il y a beaucoup
d'autres sites voilà
et donc en ville et il y a effectivement
des des événements notamment culturels
l'avaient évoqué qui qui voudrait bien
continuer oui Mathilde
c'est intéressant de ça ce qui est
important c'est de savoir qui fait quoi
notamment avec le Comité olympique les
forces de l'ordre enfin voilà il y a
toute une chaîne de commandement en fait
qui va devoir se ce coordonner
son rapport la semaine dernière alors
j'ai plus le texte exact mais on parlait
un petit peu d'une commitologie à
resserrer alors c'est c'est dit
gentiment en clair faut arrêter de de
faire des réunions pour agir davantage
il y a trop de chefs
moi pardon c'est ma culture militaire il
y a un chef une mission des moyens
l'avantage c'est que là on a beaucoup de
chefs bon de temps en temps peut-être
qu'une petite coordination serait
intéressante et en tout cas voilà à
travailler Mathieu peut toujours sur les
leçons à tirer de de ce qui s'est passé
au Stade de France dans la perspective
des Jeux Olympiques j'envoie deux la
première leçon c'est effectivement sur
la coordination et qui décide le Stade
de France qu'on a vu c'est tout le monde
qui se rejoint les responsabilités le
ministère de l'Intérieur la préfecture
de police la SNCF la RATP le Stade de
France les vidéos ont été perdu c'est
pas de notre faute enfin voilà il y a eu
cette espèce de ping-pong et qui encore
une fois de l'extérieur puisqu'on
parlait des des Anglais a été perçu de
façon cataclysmique a été vraiment une
répercussions terrible sur l'image de la
France mais encore une fois le cœur du
problème c'est l'organisation les
répercussions sur les supporters anglais
eux-mêmes et donc sur les les gens qui
assisteront aux JO donc c'est avoir une
vraie coordination et comme ça bien ça
vient d'être dit par par le général
un vrai décideur ensuite il y a la
question de la gestion des flux
correctement les flux alors justement
tiens là-dessus on va on va reprendre le
rapport de la Cour des comptes et
écouter son premier président Pierre
Moscovici justement sur la question du
recrutement
la cour alerté sur ce point des le
printemps dernier elle a pris note de
disposition mise en œuvre tant par
l'État que par le COGEP par la branche
de sécurité privée pour tenter de
remédier à la difficulté structurelle ou
aux difficultés structurelles de cette
branche en France
mais nous estimons prudents là encore
c'est pas un scénario noir mais c'est un
scénario quand même qui nous paraît très
probable de prévoir des scénarios
d'adaptation en cas de carence partielle
nous nous y attendons pour le dire
plutôt franchement et le précédent des
Jeux Olympiques de Londres oblige en
vérité à s'y préparer que la Cour a
recommandé de faire monter en charge les
réserves opérationnels de la police
nationale et la gendarmerie mais aussi
d'anticiper les conditions de mobilité
d'appels éventuels aux forces armées
alors Richard les forces les réserves
opérationnelles la gendarmerie et de la
police c'est quoi alors les réserves
opérationnelles de la jambe nationale
c'est 30 000 personnels et la police je
pense qu'on est autour de 10000 ceci
étant je rappelle donc en réserviste
c'est pas quelqu'un qui est tenu de
répondre à une convocation en fait les
réponses il a envie de répondre ensuite
quand on déplace des réservistes il faut
savoir les loger il faut savoir les
nourrir il y a une logistique derrière
donc parisienne donc aujourd'hui on a je
sais qu'il y a déjà la suppression des
congés pour les policiers des gendarmes
donc bon déjà il y a monté en puissance
la sécurité privée c'est pas une
nouveauté ça fait deux ans trois ans
qu'ils alertent sur l'impossibilité qui
est la leur c'est même plus une
hypothèse c'est une impossibilité qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont communiqué donc ils ont
fait part au gouvernement et donc on
sait très bien que les forces armées les
armées en fait se seront engagés très
clairement il faut pas partir du
principe que ça n'arrivera pas ça
arrivera la question c'est de
s'organiser la difficulté c'est qu'on a
alors on a effectivement des sites
déconcentrés on en a Bordeaux on a un
certain nombre de sites mais la plaque
parisienne c'est elle qui concentre à
peu près 80% des événements et donc il
va falloir trouver des hébergements et
mettre en place une logistique alors
même qu'il y a des athlètes alors même
qu'il y a des délégations alors même
qu'il y a des touristes donc le sujet
aujourd'hui il est aussi logistique il
est aussi dans la planification la
planification aujourd'hui c'est quelque
chose qui qui n'attendra pas et là pour
le coup je suis pas sûr qu'on soit tout
à fait dans les clous dans le calendrier
dans le rétroplanning on est peut-être
un peu en retard en tout cas si on lit
la Cour des comptes on a quelques petits
sujets de logistique de signatures de
contrat enfin bon c'est que c'est
clairement exprimé donc là à un moment
donné la logistique c'est celle qui
tient l'efficacité quelqu'un disait la
logistique suivra c'est faux c'est
totalement faux c'est la logistique qui
permettra à l'événement de se dérouler
en de bonnes conditions si on fait un
focus Gaetan Morin sur la question de
des sociétés de sécurité privée on peut
dire les vigiles pour pour simplifier
cette pénurie de vigile elle existe
effectivement déjà notamment les clubs
de football professionnel ils sont
confrontés à ça depuis plusieurs mois
tout à fait déjà alors juste Paris 2024
a compris en tout cas qu'il aurait enfin
qui avait un problème sécuritaire auprès
des sociétés privées puisqu'elles ont
alerté ils ont fait deux choses par
rapport à ça la première c'est qu'ils
ont augmenté leur budget il est passé à
320 millions d'euros pour pour la
sécurité de manière justement à être
plus attractif en termes de rémunération
ça suffira pas
la deuxième chose c'est qu'ils
envisagent d'autres moyens on a parlé de
la réserve il y a aussi la
réserve entre guillemets des écoles de
police et de gendarmerie qui pourraient
du coup contribuer à l'effort j'allais
dire l'effort de guerre mais c'est
presque ça
et il faut quand même revenir une
seconde sur Skype et Pierre Moscovici
c'est le précédent de Londres le
précédent de Londres deux semaines avant
les Jeux 2012 la société privée qui
avait raflé l'appel d'offres n'a pas été
en dit qu'elle n'était pas en mesure de
fournir les agents de sécurité promis
ils avaient pas réussi à recruter
suffisamment et donc l'armée a du palier
à ça même pas la moitié prévu ils
étaient censés fournir 10000 personnes
c'est la société G4S qui est l'un des
géants mondiaux de la qui ont été privé
il devait fournir 10000 agents et je
crois une quinzaine de jours avant les
Jeux ils disent on en a que 4500 et donc
en fait les Anglais enfin les
Britanniques ont dû faire appel à
l'armée pour compenser ce manque dans
l'urgence donc d'où l'importance de
d'anticiper
il y a une question d'attractivité de
des métiers Mathieu zagrowski c'est
alors là aussi est-ce que est-ce que
c'est trop tard je ne sais pas mais
comment redonner envie de devenir agent
de sécurité peut-être à l'occasion d'un
événement comme les Jeux Olympiques
c'est ça peut être un argument
d'ailleurs oui ça peut l'être c'est
compliqué alors il y a la question
salariale qui est essentielle ce sont
des comment dire des métiers
relativement peu qualifiés enfin qui
sont qualifiés mais mal payés souvent
SMIC horaire avec en fait beaucoup de
très petites entreprises qui ont des
marges très très faibles donc c'est
c'est compliqué en fait aujourd'hui
d'attirer et il y a une des perditions
au moment du covid c'est-à-dire que au
moment du covid vous avez mentionné les
clubs de football professionnel qui sont
effectivement en première ligne face à
cette problématique covid vous avez
l'arrêt des compétitions puis la reprise
des compétitions qui se déroule pendant
à peu près une saison entière à huis
clos donc en fait
il y a besoin de il y a plus du tout ou
très très peu et beaucoup se retrouvent
en chômage partiel et en fait se
reconvertissent soit dans d'autres
branches de la sécurité privée parce
qu'il y a d'autres besoins bah il faut
contrôler les passes sanitaires à
l'entrée des marges des marchés de Noël
et c'est un peu moins pénible que
travailler sur un stade de football à
21h un samedi d'autres seront
convertisent dans les métiers connexes
moi je connais par exemple des cas de
gens qui sont devenus médiateurs pour
pour des municipalités voilà et donc là
la question c'est
recréer l'attractivité vous l'avez dit
alors il y a la question des salaires il
y a Gérald Darmanin qui avait 1000 idées
de faciliter l'accès à la profession par
exemple de délivrer des accréditations
temporaires pour des étudiants par
exemple qui voudraient faire ça en job
d'été alors par ailleurs il y a aussi un
changement réglementaire je crois qui
est que il faut justifier d'un permis de
séjour de 5 ans absolument et ça aussi
ça a changé un peu la donne absolument
ça change la donne parce que encore une
fois ça attire plutôt des gens précaires
relativement peu qualifiés et donc
souvent des gens qui sont qui sont
d'immigration relativement récentes
d'accord ils sont arrivés en France peu
de temps auparavant ça veut dire que il
va falloir mobiliser l'armée très
clairement c'est déjà sûr mais combien
c'est là là aussi la capacité de
mobilisation de l'armée française en
homme à l'occasion d'un événement comme
celui-là sans alors je sais qu'on est un
peu moins présent notamment dans les
pays d'Afrique mais bon est-ce que c'est
une vraie question ça c'est un vrai
sujet puisque les armées sont déjà
impliquées dans l'opération sentinelle
au quotidien vous avez plusieurs
milliers bon ça varie de cet à 10000
aujourd'hui on est sur un seuil bas mais
donc il y a déjà un certain nombre de
camarades des armées qui sont impliqués
dans la sécurité publique vous avez les
opérations extérieures alors
effectivement il y a moins de monde en
Afrique mais enfin bon ça reste là pour
le coup vraiment la marge
après l'évaluation est compliquée à
faire parce que effectivement il faut
avoir l'équation à la fin accessoirement
certains moyens technologiques qu'on en
parlera certainement on y vient
permettront de diminuer le besoin en
force humaine et c'est ça qui
intéressant de la technologie c'est
qu'elle permet aussi de gagner des
effectifs et alors s'agissant des
effectifs le mauvais côté si je puis
dire de l'histoire c'est aussi les
bénévoles dont on a besoin on a besoin
de 35 à 40 000 bénévoles qui pour le
coup ne pourront pas aller dans les
fonctions sécurité donc on a on a
finalement un espace de recrutement
assez périmétré assez limité et là
dedans on va la sécher avec des
bénévoles donc du coup resteront
effectivement un certain nombre de gens
la sécurité privée étant des gens
engagée par ailleurs dans des contrats
de long terme quelqu'un préférera rester
je parle le chef d'entreprise préfère
rester sur ces contrats annuels plutôt
que de prendre
deux mois ou aux Jeux Olympiques
qui va être obligé de les licencier 4
mois après c'est quand même une équation
économique extrêmement difficile un
chiffre pour ouvrir notre dernier
chapitre donc consacré effectivement au
moyen technologiques aux caméras de
vidéos surveillance à la question de la
reconnaissance faciale ce chiffre c'est
13 millions 13 millions de spectateurs
venus d'un peu partout dans le monde qui
sont attendus en France à l'occasion de
ces Jeux Olympiques la plupart
d'ailleurs on aurait de faire un
chapitre de transport mais on peut pas
tout dire non on se débat même si on a
du temps ils vont utiliser toujours des
transports en commun avec les dans
lequel les usagers seront peut-être
aussi là même si on est au cœur de l'été
bref ça c'est un autre thème on y
viendra sûrement mais il va bien falloir
la surveiller évidemment cette foule est
là quand un calmer peu nous rejoindre
tout de suite sur ce plateau il y a la
question Quentin de la reconnaissance
faciale et on voit monter voilà un débat
ou peut-être même une polémique sur le
recours à la reconnaissance faciale
voilà notamment à l'occasion de l'examen
du projet de loi sur les jeux olympiques
qui commencent donc qui a commencé cet
après-midi au Sénat tout à fait pour
être précis le texte actuellement
débattu dans l'hémicycle permet
d'autoriser la mise en place de caméras
dites augmentées qu'elles soient
statique ou sur des drones concrètement
des programmes informatiques vont
permettre de repérer des mouvements de
foule ou des comportements douteux
ensuite les images seront transmises à
la police et donc et beaucoup il tenait
il y a toujours une intervention semaine
à la clé ces algorithmes ne pourront pas
utiliser la reconnaissance faciale ni
même le croisement avec d'autres
fichiers par exemple des fichiers de
personnes recherchées par exemple et ce
au grand dames d'un sénateur qu'on a
interrogé cet après-midi il s'appelle
Marc Philippe de Brest lui il aurait
aimé les différer tout de suite dans ce
sens même si les conscients qu'il s'agit
bien d'un débat de société ce sont ces
mots écoutés quand on l'a rencontré cet
après-midi
j'étais mère pendant 30 ans l'acte le
plus traumatisant pour moi c'est que je
suis allé annoncer à une famille qu'elle
venait de perdre son fils assassiné au
Bataclan 27 ans son fils je souhaite de
tout mon coeur qui n'y est pas
d'attentat mais si alors qu'on avait les
moyens en préservant les libertés de
donner à la police plus d'outils pour
prévenir tout risque terroriste si
malheureusement tragiquement il y en a
on portera une lourde responsabilité
voilà très solennelle marqué mais il
donne un exemple sur les trois années
précédant les JO 24 différentes
personnes condamnées pour acte
terroriste auront été libérés et alors
qu'il dit que le procureur national
anti-terroriste à alerter contre le fort
risque de récidive de ces anciens
détenus alors pourquoi ne pas avoir
ajouté la reconnaissance faciale et bien
le sujet Thomas est bientôt polémique
l'opinion publique rejette massivement
cette reconnaissance faciale la CNIL la
Commission Nationale Informatique et
Liberté a déjà parlé de tournant rien
qu'avec les mesures que je vous donnais
au début de cette chronique et donc il
faut un débat posé à part sur le sujet
estime les sénateurs dans un contexte
apaisé écouter un autre sénateur il est
centriste s'appelle Loïc Hervé et il est
membre de la CNIL écoutez-le
la question de la reconnaissance faciale
dans notre pays doit se faire au terme
d'un débat
nourri ou il faut encore une fois peser
mais lourdement les conséquences que ça
peut avoir sur notre vie quotidienne et
sur l'exercice de liberté publique une
fois que l'outil sera dans le droit on
sait très bien qu'on ira vers d'autres
utilisations je prends un exemple on
peut nous dire tiens utilisons la
reconnaissance faciale pour réguler les
interdits de stade oui mais si nous
faisons ça demain une police municipale
nous demandera la reconnaissance faciale
pour faire baliser automatiquement des
personnes qu'on rejué un papier gras
dans la rue
ça fait réagir sur votre plateau le
sénateur qui parle de bascule majeur que
représentés que représente très le fait
de doter des caméras de surveillance de
logiciels de reconnaissance faciale le
Sénat pourrait revenir cela dit sur ce
débat très bientôt puisque Marc Philippe
de Bresse entend bien proposer poser une
proposition de loi sur ce sujet et elle
sera prête le mois prochain intime merci
général lesuré vous vous réagissiez
effectivement à cette chronique et
notamment à cette polémique sur la
reconnaissance faciale vous dites quoi
vous dites il faut se doter de tous les
outils possibles avant cette échéance
alors moi je considère que l'objectif
c'est la sécurité des citoyens je vois
spectateurs participants ou autre pour
ça il faut mettre en place tous les
dispositifs et utiliser tous les moyens
évidemment la reconnaissance faciale
indiscriminée indifférencier on
reconnaît tout le monde je suis à titre
personnel contre ça ne me paraît
d'ailleurs pas utile
après quand j'entends les choses
caricaturales sur le thème si on fait ça
la police municipale va demander enfin
faut être sérieux les gens sont
responsables
en revanche 240 personnes qui présentent
un risque de récidive terroriste quasi
avéré puisque c'est quand même un
magistrat qu'il dit je pense que il
serait pas complètement incohérent de
les rentrer dans une base déficitations
alors on a des fichiers de sexuels on a
des fichiers de gens violents on a des
gens qui ont des bracelets électroniques
on a déjà des dispositifs pourquoi ne
pourrait-on pas rentrer ces gens sur
décision du cirque dans une base qui
nous permet de dire bah tiens attention
Monsieur Untel
convaincu d'actes terroristes et
condamnés pour ça il est présent autour
du stade de France
faciale il faut insisterbe
d'identification financière la
reconnaissance faciale c'est une espèce
de totem on met tout dedans la
reconnaissance faciale pour moi c'est
quelque chose qui est indiscriminé c'est
à dire on met une caméra dans la rue on
connaît tout le monde Je resp persuadé
que on met en place la technologie
nécessaire pour m'identifier que les
gens qui existent dans un fichier c'est
ce qu'on appelle l'identification
faciale quand vous passez à l'aéroport
vous avez le sas paraphe c'est quoi
c'est de l'identification faciale pour
vous êtes bien dans une base ça marche
pas à chaque fois alors ça c'est
d'accord avec vous ça marche pas mais on
a un certain vous avez des gens si sur
leur téléphone ils ont une
reconnaissance faciale pour le coup bon
mais à ce moment-là c'est quelque chose
qui est volontaire qui doit être encadré
en utilisant le d'une façon
ce que vous dites c'est que on pourrait
mettre en place ce genre d'outils
ponctuellement pour des grands
événements parce qu'en fait le politique
se dit que ça crée forcément un
précédent
la critique qui est qui est exprimée
sur un événement monétaire on l'a dit
sur une menace potentiellement majeure
un moment donné prenons les moyens et
effectivement là je suis d'accord avec
allez le sénateur si si ça arrive on
dira pourquoi alors il nous reste deux
minutes donc je voudrais vous entendre
l'un et l'autre là-dessus peut-être
Mathieu Zago ski pour pour commencer
il faut y aller jusque là
l'identification faciale ces outils là
pendant les Jeux olympiques ou est-ce
qu'on peut s'en passer je suis dubitatif
pas tant d'un point de vue philosophique
enfin la question philosophique des
libertés essentielles personnellement je
me situe plus sur le calcul le coût
avantage deux exemples la police de San
Francisco s'en est servi pendant 7 ans
et abandonné la reconnaissance faciale
c'est pas assez fiable ça leur a servi à
rien on l'a déployé sur la finale de la
Ligue des Champions 2018 à Cardiff il y
a eu je me souviens plus de la
proportion il y a un nombre de faux soit
de de faux positif qui était très
significatif je suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui ça pourrait presque faire
perdre du temps c'est exactement ça
pourrait faire perdre du temps d'autant
plus à une l'époque où on nous parle de
de dépenses publiques de déficit est-ce
que engloutiant des millions dans une
technologie qui est totalement fiable
aujourd'hui je suis pas totalement
convaincu ça peut avoir un intérêt pour
les organisateurs d'événements enfin
qu'est-ce qui met en avant en terme de
fluidification voilà c'est que un mode
conclusion Gaetan Mora est-ce que est-ce
que les voilà vous baignez à la fois
dans le milieu sportif et politique
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
inquiets quand vous parlez des Jeux
Olympiques oui alors de toute façon on
est souvent inquiet en France mais
effectivement
là on est à un ennemi un an et demi de
l'événement et en termes de sécurité en
termes de transport en commun on n'y est
pas encore la question des transports
effectivement mais on a encore un peu de
temps devant nous ce sera certainement
l'objet d'un débat transport et Jeux
Olympiques tiens je le note dans un coin
parce qu'il promet d'être passionnant
merci à tous d'avoir participé à cette
émission je vous dis à bientôt sur sur
public c'est la voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro de sens public ce soir je me
souviens du nom de l'émission ça tombe
bien prochain rendez-vous c'est sur
notre antenne prochain rendez-vous
politique Oriane Mancini reçoit Nicolas
Mayer Rossignol le maire de Rouen
évidemment hier elle avait oublié fort
et Nicolas Mayer rossino qui conteste
toujours les résultats du vote interne
[Musique]